[Musica]
[Applauso]
il primo ricordo che ho del concetto di
confine risale alla mia infanzia
passavamo l'estate in liguria è un
giorno i miei genitori decisero di fare
una gita in costa azzurra e ora
citatissimo non ero mai stato fuori
dall'italia per me la francia era un
paese esotico avevo aspettative enormi
anche se molto confuse su quello che
avrei trovato una volta al di là
arrivammo al valico di ventimiglia
ricordo i nostri finanzieri in gendarmi
francesi
alla fine degli anni sessanta esiste un
confine fisico fra italia francia una
volta attraversato lo la mia delusione
fu totale era tutto uguale lo stesso
cielo lo stesso mare la stessa
vegetazione
ricordo che mi chiesi è un bimbo ma se è
tutto uguale perché esiste una frontiera
a che cosa serve ora non so se la mia
fuga verso un mondo senza frontiere sia
iniziata in quel momento quello che
posso dirvi è che facendo l'astrofisico
il cosmologo cioè studiando come
l'entità che chiamiamo universo evolve
nel tempo e nello spazio
l'unico vero confine che si incontra e
quello del proprio intelletto almeno del
mio che spinto veramente all'estremo nel
tentativo di dare un senso ai dati che
raccogliamo nel cosmo le distanze
diventano numeri enormi a cui
corrispondono tempi vertiginosamente
lontani ricordiamolo guardare lontano
significa guardare indietro nel tempo
io vedo voi come eravate una frazione di
secondo fa il tempo che la luce ha
impiegato per andare da dove siete voi a
dove sono io
un tempo piccolissimo ma finito
quantificabile se sola esplodesse in
questo preciso istante
noi ce ne accorgeremo solofra circa 8
minuti
quello che sappiamo è che l'universo si
sta espandendo
lo spazio si stira trascinando con sé le
galassie con il risultato che ogni
galassia si allontana da tutte le altre
attenzione non esiste il centro comune
dal quale le galassie si allontanano
ogni galassia si allontana da tutti gli
altri
immaginate di prendere un palloncino sul
quale avete disegnato dei puntini le
vostre galassie e di gonfiarlo ogni
puntino si allontana da tutti gli altri
ora fate questo esercizio
girati alla freccia del tempo sgonfiate
il palloncino cosa concludete
necessariamente che tutto deve aver
avuto un inizio che lo spazio del tempo
sia anche il tempo non esistono da
sempre
semplicemente sempre non esiste i
cosmologi e gli astronomi possono datare
questo inizio a circa 14 miliardi di
anni fa in un evento ancora piuttosto
misterioso che chiamiamo big bang 14
miliardi di anni un tempo difficile da
immaginare se lo paragoniamo ai tempi
della della storia umana è un tempo
difficile da immaginare in cui collocare
un evento quasi impossibile da
immaginare lo sviluppo tecnologico
dell'astronomia degli ultimi dieci anni
ci permette di osservare galassie del
tutto simile alla nostra
la cui luce che ci raggiunge oggi è
stata emessa e quindi ci racconta di
come era l'universo meno di un miliardo
di anni dopo il big bang ma possiamo
guardare più lontano cioè spingerci più
indietro nel tempo
osserviamo cose che accadevano quando
l'universo aveva meno di 400.000 anni
400.000 anni un tempo molto piccolo se
lo paragonate ai 14 miliardi di anni
della vita attuale dell'universo e come
se noi dell'intera esistenza di un
essere umano adulto osservassimo il suo
primo giorno di vita
ricordate quando la televisione era
analogica con il suo tubo catodico da 30
chili fuori sintonia quello che vedeva
te sul vostro schermo era un insieme di
puntini luminosi che apparivano e
scomparivano in modo più o meno
incoerente e quello che chiamiamo il
rumore cioè l'insieme di tutte le
sorgenti di onde radio che si trovavano
nei dintorni della vostra casa stazioni
fm stazioni televisive forni a microonde
bene ogni mille di quei puntini che
vedevate almeno uno non proveniva da
un'antenna dietro casa vostra ma da
molto più lontano un puntino era un
fotone c'è un quanto di radiazione che
aveva viaggiato 14 miliardi di anni
un viaggio iniziato quando non
esistevano ancora le galassie le stelle
i pianeti non esistevano nemmeno i
elementi che formano il nostro corpo
come il carbonio o l'ossigeno quello che
vedeva the nascosto nel segnale fuori
sintonia della vostra vecchia
televisione analogica era l'eco di
qualcosa accaduto 14 miliardi di anni fa
era l'eco del big bang ma possiamo
spingerci più lontano con le nostre
teorie e avere un'idea abbastanza
precisa di quello che accadeva anche
prima
l'universo per definizione è illimitato
cioè non ha confini
potrebbe però essere finito il limitato
è finito non c'è contraddizione in
questo la superficie di una sfera il
palloncino di prima per degli ipotetici
essere in due dimensioni che vivono
sopra di essa è esattamente questo è
illimitata ma finita oggi sappiamo però
che molto probabilmente l'universo in
cui viviamo
oltre ad essere limitato è davvero anche
infinito non la superficie di una sfera
piuttosto un foglio senza margini quello
che è finito sono i 14 miliardi di anni
della sua esistenza
con il risultato che noi possiamo
osservare oggi solo una parte di questo
infinito foglio
esiste quindi un orizzonte che chiamiamo
orizzonte cosmologico come fosse
l'orizzonte del mare oltre l'orizzonte
esistono spiagge del tutto simili in
quella in cui vorremmo trovarci in
questo momento semplicemente la loro
immagine la loro luce non ha ancora
avuto il tempo di raggiungerci
ma l'orizzonte non è un confine non sia
attraverso un orizzonte l'orizzonte che
cerchiamo di raggiungere si sposta
sempre più lontano sempre più in avanti
da un certo punto di vista è l'esatto
contrario di una frontiera bene per
studiare questo universo in cui esistono
orizzonti ma non esistono confini
gli scienziati di un minuscolo pianeta
che orbita questa stella ordinaria una
fra le 100 miliardi di stelle che
popolano la nostra galassia che a sua
volta è una fra le mille miliardi di
galassie che esistono nel nostro
orizzonte non sto dicendo numeri
inventati questi astronomi
quotidianamente attraverso le frontiere
che dividono
attraversano confini burocratici
amministrativi politici comunque confini
fittizi come quello che attraversati da
bambino a ventimiglia una volta di la
senta davvero in un mondo senza barriere
in cui non conta chi sei ma solo quello
che sai non conta da dove vieni ma
semplicemente quello che puoi imparare
dagli altri quello che gli altri possono
imparare da te italia francia e stati
uniti argentina brasile russia giappone
e tanti altri posti nelle cui università
enti di ricerca laboratori io sono stato
negli ultimi 30 anni
a volte fermandomi c per anni altre
volte solo per qualche giorno
esiste una lingua comune per per
comunicare che noi chiamiamo broken
english ai tempi del ai tempi di newton
era il latino e quindi siamo fortunati
diciamo ma la vera lingua comune e la
scienza la fisica la matematica in ogni
paese ho incontrato sempre la medesima
attitudine verso la ricerca la stessa
tensione intellettuale la stessa etica
in un laboratorio sei sempre dove 66
come collocarti se è come essere te
stesso in una comunità che cerca di
comprendere il presente guardando nel
passato e immaginandosi il futuro
i tuoi colleghi parlano la tua stessa
lingua pensano nella tua stesso identico
modo
vivono la ricerca come la vedi tu col
tuo stesso spirito la stessa dedizione e
lo stesso obiettivo è lo stesso piacere
perché il piacere un ininfluente queste
scelte come ha detto richard feynman uno
dei grandi scienziati del novecento
studiando l'universo la nostra
immaginazione ed il piacere di usarla
aggiungo io e spinto all'estremo non per
immaginare cose che non esistono come
lui film della marvel ad esempio ma
piuttosto per cercare di comprendere
quello che esiste allora la
straordinaria immagine del buco nero di
m 87 nella glassa della vergine che i
maggio molti di voi avranno visto
recentemente è stata ottenuta combinando
le osservazioni di radiotelescopio
appartenenti a nazioni di tutto il mondo
sparsi sulla superficie di tutto il
pianeta
la i dati che hanno dimostrato losco
contro la fusione di due stelle di
neutroni del 2017 sono stati acquisiti
coordinando telescopi interferometri e
satelliti appartenenti ancora una volta
a diversi semi paesi nel mondo
i telescopi dell'eso european southern
observatory un consorzio di 16 nazioni
europee sono posizionati in vari punti
nel deserto di atacama nel nord del cile
e potrei andare avanti a lungo i
successi della dell'astronomia globale
in generale della scienza dimostra non
solo che è possibile ma che è necessario
coordinare gli sforzi di uomini e donne
di paesi lontani e diversi per
raggiungere un obiettivo comune
in questo caso stiamo parlando di
soddisfare l'innata sete di sapere che
era sempre spinge l'uomo a domandarsi il
perché il mondo è come appare
alcuni di noi non si accontentano di
risposte mutuate da miti da leggende o
da religioni ma come ha detto steven
weber un altro grande scienziato del
novecento
alcuni uomini e donne passano loro
esistenza a cercare di dare un senso e
dati che raccolgono nel tentativo di
elevare la vita umana dal livello di
farsa conferendole un po della dignità
di una tragedia
ora di prima mattina tutto questo tutto
questo pessimismo cosmico forse un po di
di turba non dimenticate però che la
ricerca di base non è distinta dallo
sviluppo generalizzato della nostra
società in tutti i suoi aspetti
gli scienziati che si interrogano
sull'origine dell'universo creano una
rete di sapere sviluppando tecniche e
conoscenze che hanno un impatto
fondamentale nella nostra vita
studiare i buchi neri all evoluzione del
cosmo oil bosone di higgs oltre ad
essere per alcuni talmente affascinante
da farci la propria professione ha come
effetto collaterale lo sviluppo di
tecniche e di conoscenze che poi
troviamo ad esempio nella medicina
diagnostica o nei dispositivi di
geolocalizzazione che sono ai vostri
smartphone dispositivi che senza
l'equazione di ashan del 1915 non
funzionerebbero è studiando e cercando
di capire cose che accadranno accadute
in tempi e luoghi vertiginosamente
lontani e quindi apparentemente
lontanissimi la nostra vita quotidiana
che sono state sviluppate tecnologie
le conoscenze che ci permettono di
curarci di volare di navigare su
internet e di non perderci quando quando
guidiamo per arrivare qui ad esempio ma
la scienza per potersi evolvere e
portare reali benefici alla comunità
degli umani deve necessariamente essere
libera libera di trasferirsi da una
mente all'altra da un laboratorio
all'altro da un telescopio e piedi alle
ande a un satellite che orbita intorno
alla terra fino magari a un rover che
sta arrancando in questo momento sulla
superficie sulla superficie di marte la
collaborazione scientifica
internazionale può dare una lezione
importante alla comunità degli umani
specialmente alla politica che mai come
in questo periodo storico sembra invece
tanto concentrata a contarsi in base a
categorie inesistenti o quantomeno
contingenti penso alla razza
l'orientamento sessuale al prodotto
interno lordo pensa a non collaborare
invece che a collaborare a costruire
muri invece che a creare degli spazi
aperti a chiudersi dentro confini
invalicabili invece che ad abbattere
quelli esistenti ma la politica oggi il
dovere di imparare dalla comunità
scientifica internazionale per
affrontare in modo coordinato e efficace
la grande sfida che l'umanità si trova a
dover affrontare in questo periodo
storico
una sfida davvero globale per la propria
esistenza rispondere in modo coordinato
ed efficace ai cambiamenti climatici
prima che sia troppo tardi parliamoci
chiaro per l'ecologia dell'universo
l'esistenza della razza umana della
terra della nostra galassia è
assolutamente irrilevante ma noi siamo
qui ora ed è nostro preciso dovere avere
cura della casa nella quale il destino o
qualcos'altro per chi ci crede ci ha
concesso di vivere e per fare questo
dobbiamo trasformare i confini in
orizzonti come ha detto yuri gagarin nel
suo primo viaggio orbitare intorno alla
terra il mondo da quassù è bellissimo
senza confini e senza frontiere grazie
[Musica]